new Disney movie should make for some
fun ZZZ Zootopia
before we get started in this review I'm
gonna tell you guys this video is
brought to you by loot crate if you
don't know what loot crate is I have no
idea what rock you've been living under
monthly subscription service less than
20 bucks a month I sent you a box full
of nerdy stuff that you don't need you
probably love to have so Zootopia is a
Disney animated film about a place
Zootopia
animals ultimately now have the
characteristics of human beings but they
still look like the animals they are
otherwise known as most any Disney movie
ever I know I had to explain that just
now because at this Disney it's what
they do there's a city called Zootopia
that ultimately accommodates a lot of
the habitats of a lot of different
animals they all live there in harmony
kind of Oh mostly in harmony kind of in
harmony like human beings live in
harmony worth like in harmony but not
does they put up with a lot of the
social stigmas that we human beings in
our world put up with and that's some of
the point in this movie this movie
addresses social issues that we human
beings deal with but it's like animals
the main star of this movie is Judy
Hopps she's a little bunny rabbit who
wants to be a cop in Zootopia it's
really unusual because usually the cops
are these huge animals with big stature
but not Judy Hopps she's a little bunny
rabbit but she has heart and she wants
to make a difference no one's taking her
seriously and then she runs across it's
really slick fox named nick wilde he's a
con artist and they together trying to
solve a missing person really and this
movie was really cool it's really cute
it's really enjoyable first of all I
loved the chemistry between these two
often while we're both awesome if I can
have a t-shirt with the Fox on it I will
get it this is one of the coolest slick
sly animals I've seen in a movie in a
while probably because most of the
movies i watch with animals they don't
actually talk probably why this one's a
little slicker than most so now the
movie hit the note that was going for it
succeeded in doing what it was trying to
do which is entertain us and tregos have
great banter between two great
characters and more importantly
metaphorically in kind of an on the
knows fashion address social issues and
parameters that we human beings do I
thought it was an interesting way of
doing it but we see it on Facebook day
and day out all the time they're called
tweets and posts and we see them
everywhere when you do them in an
entertaining movie with animals as a
metaphor it's a little funnier in a way
that's accessible another great thing
about this movie is the animals they
walk talk like human beings but they
haven't lost any other animal
characteristics and when you take animal
characteristics and apply it to human
beings it just it makes for some really
funny stuff
we are just as absurd we're probably
more absurd than any animal like in
background you take the duck-billed
platypuses I'm like I've seen weirder in
human beings it's really hard to find a
movie that can entertain kids and adults
alike you usually it's like hey this
movie is for kids adults are gonna be
bored I think that most movies that are
aimed towards kids try to hit both
demographics Zootopia is one of those
rare cases run like that succeeded
adults and kids are both going to have a
good time in this movie ultimately
Zootopia was a great time it had great
characters great chemistry between the
two characters this is some solid
animating chemistry right here had good
intrigue good comedy which surprised me
I mean it's February I'm not saying all
movies in February are bad
clearly I'm just say February doesn't
strike me as a time when Disney's gonna
make their move with a really good movie
like this but they didn't I will say
Zootopia is definitely worth watching
and definitely worth buying on blu-ray
and remember this video is brought to
you by loot crate you can use promo code
Jeremy John's save yourself 10% the
theme in March is versus check this out
on their website they're like all right
bye versus we mean Dark Knight versus
Man of Steel alien versus Predator Spock
versus mirror Spock I don't know it's in
this curry I don't know if there is an
evil Spock goatee in the I'm just saying
if there is an evil Spock goatee I'm
wearing it all the time ISIL Zootopia
have you seen it what did you think
about it what's your favorite Disney
animated movie post the year 2000 oh
yeah I know going back to the classics
post 2000 whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you